over the past few months ko has become
an essential part of pro-valerian he can
be a game-breaking pick for most teams
but for whatever reason you guys refuse
to pick him in ranked so i decided to
take matters into my own hands and make
a guide for arguably his best map ascent
here are some essential knives and
mollies you'll need to know
[Applause]
all right so as soon as the round starts
you're probably going to want to throw
ko's knife somewhere the quicker you use
it then the faster you'll get it back
and you can use it again throughout the
round but to start things off let's take
a look at b site on defense so as ko
your job is to gather info for your team
and to use your utility to stop pushes
so a good knife to start the round is to
throw one here be man
and that'll let you know if there are
any enemies nearby so keep in mind that
attackers are eventually gonna gonna
know that you're throwing it back here
so you can start throwing it closer to
you here you can throw it along this
entire wall
and if you throw it here they won't
actually be able to shoot the knife
which is a bonus so if your opponents
have already made it onto the site then
chances are this is going to be smoked
off and you're going to be forced to
retake so here's a molly that can
prevent plant from going down
you bank it off the wall there and it
just lands default and lastly i want to
show you guys a lineup that can destroy
killjoy's lockdown if it's placed beam
in so what you do is you go into this
corner here
and you're going to line your crosshair
up with this pipe that's in the middle
of the window
and there's this line that goes
across the window here
you're going to aim in between this line
and the top of the window
and throw
and it lands just on the corner of the
box so it'll destroy the lockdown next
let's take a look at some options for
playing mid like most defender side
knives using ko zero point is pretty
situational so you can throw one here to
clear tiles you can throw one over there
to clear top mid and attackers won't be
able to shoot it because it's on the
other side of each wall if you're smoked
off mid round and you're looking for
info then sometimes i like to just knife
here that way you know if someone's up
close or you can knife here and you can
see if there's a potential cat push
going on now let's check out a site so
if you're starting around in a main then
a simple knife like this will give you
all of the info that you need you can
hit a similar spot from back here on
heaven but you just want to make sure
that it's not too close to the corner of
the wall otherwise your enemies could
potentially well bang it you can also
knife along this wall mid round to
gather info
if you're playing garden or tree then
you can knife here to see if anybody has
made their way of cat and you can also
knife your teammates on a man here if
you're playing on cad at the start of
the round then you can quickly send a
knife over to tiles to get info for the
rest of your team lastly here's a molly
that can help deny default plan so what
we're going to do is we're going to line
our crosshair up with this line here and
we're going to aim just above it and
we're going to run forward and throw the
molly while we jump
and we want to throw it when we pass
this part of the wall here
and that will land on the default plane
spot so one thing to keep in mind about
that molly is that it does take a couple
seconds to actually land here so you
might want to throw it before you
actually hear the spike start to go down
now let's take a look at a site on
attack so the obvious knife at the start
of the round is to throw one just above
arches here because then you'll know
someone's peeking in but sometimes i
like to throw a knife here
that way you know if someone's sitting
switch or on cat if your team is getting
ready to hit the site then here's a good
lineup that can help clear heaven and
the back of gen so what you're gonna do
is line your crosshair up with this
pointy thing here
and then you see these two clouds so
there's one here and one here
you want to go in between them
throw and you have a lot of time here so
you can even flash above
flash the site for your team and it'll
land back here so if your team wants to
do an a split and you want a clear
garden for them then here's a good knife
what you want to do is aim just the very
edge of this wall and then if you look
up there's this cloud here and there's
this roof
if you throw the knife just in between
both of them
it will land
up here
so this clears garden this clears window
part of heaven
uh and if there's a killjoy waiting to
use their lockdown here then they have
to wait even longer next let's talk
about mollies so let's say you've
already planted the bomb here and the
enemy killjoy just used her lockdown
what you want to do is line up your
crosshair just with the line of these
tiles here
and then
if you line up the edge of the icon for
chaos mollies with this wire this wire
here and the the ledge here
just like that and then throw
this will land on the other side here
and it'll destroy a lockdown if it's on
the box here the second one i saw in a
match between ryze and sonics and it's
honestly pretty cool so i want to show
you guys how to do it for this one you
want to line your character up with the
middle of this beam here
and then if you look up there's this
semicircle
being made by the clouds so if you aim
just in the middle of that and then
slightly to the right
and throw
this will land in tree
and this will prevent any defenders from
helping their team onsite so that
combined with a smoke can do some
serious damage and to finish off let's
take a look at some options for b-side
executes this basic knife can be thrown
at the start of the round and will tell
you if someone's peaking b-main or the
surrounding area a good way to change
this one up is to go back in this corner
and if you look up this cloud at least
to me looks kind of like a duck's beak
so if you aim in between the the beak
here
and throw
this knife lands on top of the roof beam
in you can also knife this tree here a
lot of sovas tend to dart that spot but
keep in mind that these last two that i
showed you can both be shot from
defenders on site so i would change it
up every round so here's a molly that
can help you hit b site you're gonna go
into this back corner here and if you
put your crosshair in between these two
bars
and then just above the windowsill
you're gonna move forward start running
forward and throw the molle almost
immediately
it's gonna bounce off that wall and hit
ct all right so that should help you get
started with some ko lineups on ascent
if you want to see more videos like this
then let us know in the comments
yeah i think you got something like two
lines in and this is a 10 minute
recording well that's
and like us know in the comments
this guy [ __ ] sucks
they'll tell you that no matter how good
you are i promise good i smiled a bit
you did i don't do that often
they don't know i smiled once
and they they don't know i hit diamond
once
[Laughter]
from back here you can run
jump and throw
it'll bank
potential end board material